jean casimir
ne soit pas si triste
je n'ai pas de ta faute si monsieur
justin b et 6 6 et 6 membres
tout ce travail pour rien quel dommage
alors et pourtant quelle entraîné ce pan
du haddock farcis à la groseille montel
des listes tu as aimé on s'était dit ni
cieux kazinian peut-être un peu sucré et
monsieur du snob lui donne à manger
qu'une toute petite cuillère est
et les huîtres des huîtres chaudes à la
sauce blanche
eh bien
tu as aimé n'est sparrow kux klan
casimir peut-être pas tout à fait assez
simple ouais mais monsieur disent non
plus a prétendu qu'il était en régime
sans sel
enfin et c est le dessert presse qu'elle
dessert extraordinaire une crème glacée
arrosé de crème meringue et avec un peu
de crème fouettée à une grosse couche de
crème fraîche nous quelle merveille tu
as aimé n'est ce pas un extraordinaire
casimir il manquait peut-être un zeste
de citron eh bien monsieur du snav lui a
demandé un yaourt c'est un peu d'être
six membres je n'oserais plus jamais
invité personnes à déjeuner cela
vaudrait mieux ils seront bien puni mais
mais mais moi un tutu m'invitera
abattoirs quoi c'est pas pareil
tant pis qu'est-ce que tu eu dix ans je
disais c'est gentil ah ben ouais ceci
dit c'est quand même triste un de
déjeuner tous les jours sol tous les
deux mais alors invite les autres voies
romaines n'aime pas ce que je fais
trouve une idée nouvelle ah ben oui mais
je ne connais pas beaucoup de recettes
attends je crois à temps j'ai trouvé
quoi j'ai trouvé tu vas leur préparer un
repas chinois chinois mais moi je n'y
connais rien mais dans mon livre les
mystérieux pékinois de hong kong on
explique tout sur la cuisine chinoise
invite tous les amis et je vais te dire
ce qu'il faut faire gérard est un repas
qui marquera dans l'histoire de l'île
c'est un sûr je suis sûr qu'on m'insulte
du snob sera le premier on chantait est
très bien
je lis françois g du courrier pour vous
aussi que c'est peut-être une surprise
tenue donnez vite facteur humain mais
voilà
ça ressemble à une invitation à c'est
une invitation à dîner de kazimiya ah
oui évidemment les invitations à dîner
de casimir enfin sa feria nous irons
avec plaisir
bonjour mes très chers amis arrangé pour
moi rochelle à 1000 j'attends une
commande presque ferme de tous mes
tableaux pour une superbe exposition à
new york je n'ai rien venant de
l'étranger non monsieur du snop aïe aïe
aïe oui enfin il ya tellement de
laiterie doivent se perdre sa maman vous
osez mais non monsieur du stop pas une
pour entendez pas une seule je dirais
même que c'est plutôt le contraire a
passé j'ai bien compris mon cher ami il
vous distribuer plus de lettres qui
l'emmenait en voyant mes amis vous savez
je vous en prie vous comme et paulo n'a
que faire
du caractère du cac je suis neuf juges
ne comprends pas c'est que ces allusions
injustifiée
pardon mon cher et mille pardons je me
suis mal exprimé
d'autant plus que j'ai une lettre pour
attendre une est une invitation à cela
dans les milieux chics on oublie pas
nous avons la même
[Musique]
bon voyons
une invitation pour dîner chez casimir
je ne suis pas libre je suis du ch ne
connaissez même pas la peine que je suis
en ce moment presque jamais libre quel
dommage que monsieur vous n'avez même
pas lui c'est une invitation à un repas
chinois mais ça change tout un symbole
pour les gens de ma qualité c'est un
devoir que de goûter à la cuisine est en
national c'est pour quand c'est pour
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure ne fait
pas manquer ça bon alors tout à l'heure
aux pages chinois je vous promet même
une surprise et non
vous avez bien de la chance d'être tous
invités
ça m'étonne ces pages c'est vrai j'ai
bien une lettre pour moi ici mais mais
mais ce que j'aime moi c'est allé
prendre mon courrier dans ma boîte aux
lettres et je ne suis pas encore passé
ce matin voilà alors je vais aller
mettre cette lettre dans ma boîte aux
lettres j'ai hâte de savoir un au revoir
mes bons amis à bientôt pour écoute
c'est beau j'ai donc oms a jailli
ce grâce à l'impression que ce serait
plus âgés dont paris qu'est ce que ce
serait je serais plus âgé qu'elle serait
de rang qui conte comme ça ce ne serait
plus un jet du tout du tout est
maintenant âgé non à nice en est plus
âgé a et c'est reposant de regarder un
jet d'eau comme ça qui jaillit et qui
murmurent les premiers jets qui veulent
en mur et non après sans le g oui non
grâce au gic qui alimente le petit
bassin en ont et comme il a tout le
temps que l'on y arrive ou frontignes et
ont tant de noms qui s'écoule et c'est
ce qui fait que l'on y en aura mais dis
moi on peut s'acheter jets d'eau comme
ça
mais il est livré jaillissant on doit
drôlement se faire mouiller pendant
transports mais non il faut d'abord le
brancher sur un robinet et c'est
seulement à ce moment là que l'on chagny
elle jaillit de joie mais france grand
bassin chinois naturel 30 on our un
robinet l'on part toujours à nous nous
nous n'ont pas toujours un pas toujours
chez moi quand on ouvre le robinet l'eau
par toujours vers le bas est un cause
d'une direction c'est parti n'est
dirigée vers le bas
et il jaillit toute l'année se joue la
havane en parapente c'est pourquoi ils
marchent pas au niveau et qu'il génère
un taux bas
qui gèlerait de peur mais non deux fois
enfin si j'irai parce que la température
descend souvent à zéro degré et que 7 à
0 de crête que l'eau shell et même
parfois elle descend en dessous de zéro
en dessous de zéro degré et parfois les
tuyaux remplis ton et quand on hiver ah
bon il éclate de rire maintenant tomba
enfin simplement parce que l'on gèle et
lo solan augmente devant lui
puis drôlement cas les toits en tout cas
moi je ne boirai plus jamais dont en
hiver
pourquoi on n'est pas fou non j'ai pas
envie d'éclater comme un tuyau mois
enfin ça y est je les lui je suis
invitée mais vous senti à 100 sûrement
allé se préparer c'est formidable d'être
un facteur c'est vrai on suit la lettre
la cajole en haut on en prend soin et au
moment de l'ouvrir
quelle émotion vous saisit
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier masson géographe
j'aurais pu même être chaud très
aurait pu un tout petit matin koffi
there to mécanographe
mais j'ai choisi d'être facteur
quand je suis le droit d'alberto grave
je suis l'ami des jolies
l'amoureux des phrases et ses vidéos je
les emporte sur mon
seule la branche ont
voté
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier maçon ou géographe
j'aurais pu même être chantre
aurait pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
ou mécanographe mais j'ai choisi d'être
pacte elle car je suis le roi de
l'orthographe
j'aime les lettres
les écritures guézé charmante quand leur
taux grimperait respecter cela montchamp
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier maçon ou géographe
j'aurais pu même être chanteur
j'aurais pu être tivat heures confiseurs
pour mecha le bras mais j'ai choisi
d'être factuel
je suis le poids de leur programme
et que commence ma tournée
tout le long du chemin
je chante les gens jettent mon arrivée
cela mangeant
j'aurais plus a confié sagher veniez
masson rouge et au drame
j'aurais pu même être chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
fou mégalomane
mais j'ai choisi d'être pas de faire
fort ce
fait je choisis des tracteurs pour sûr
mais j'ai choisi d'être un facteur
il faut que je m'en n'at il faut que
j'aille me préparer et je vais je vais
leur prépare une surprise
voilà
toute épreuve ils peuvent arriver on l'a
surprise va être tantale vénérable
casimir surtout lorsqu'il nous verrons
un billet en chinois c'est certes très
honoré lee ronda taille internautes en
plein ramadan la
tentation j'entends du bruit court
[Musique]
entre elles se disent non à baa1
je pensais qu avant mais aucun sur pige
à moi aussi je suis surpris
en très très vénérable chacun affiche
deux amis je suis sûr que personne est 6
heures ainsi au bon
[Musique]
si j'avais su je serais mieux la
première ça ne paie rien allez mes amis
passent on a
pas de façon déguisée en chinois
a donné on veut famille ou non je ne
suis pas déguiser en chinois non je suis
passé à la réserve de costumes de lille
est tout ce que j'ai trouvé c'est ce
déguisement oui tout ce qu'il y avait de
chinois avaient péri
nous avoir une surprise
a mis
ses culottes
j'en ai l'eau à la bouche sirpa promet
d'être un événement les amis comme
rappelles-tu ce plat casimir aura bien
ce sens des îles ailerons de requins
avec du poulet quand rené la sauce
moutarde et des groseilles à
casimir
quasi match à oublier les couverts ah
non pas du tout voici la surprise en
rentrant chinois doit toujours de manger
avec des paquets
c'est quasiment
tu sais t'en servir pas dit
j'ai
fait un peu attention bis n'ont vraiment
pas trop chiant je lai
[Musique]
non vous inquiétez pas j'ai tout prévu
la baguette quand je préfère la voici
et bien maintenant
bon appétit à tout ça